- The Dr. Shark Varshavski
is back in the building.
Are you ready?
Be woo.
- Hello sharks.
- Hello.
- I'm Bobby Edwards.
- Hello Bobby.
- This is my mother Judy.
- Hello, Judy.
- And we're here seeking
$350,000 for a 5% share.
- Woo ha.
- Wow, that means they're
worth quite a bit of money.
- Simply put, we're in the business
to help you do your business.
- Now there's something that each
and every one of you are
doing wrong every day
of your lives,
and it's adversely affecting your health.
- The reality is living life
is adverse to your health.
Everything you do in a given day
just by living adversely
affects the length of your life.
That doesn't mean we should
stop living our lives though,
wouldn't you agree?
- Oh, that business.
- The American toilet
- Is this that thing that
you put a stool under,
and it raises the angle?
Okay.
- We have a muscle called
the puborectalis muscle
that wraps around the base
of our colon, forming a kink.
And only when we are in a squat position
does this muscle completely relax.
- The one thing I gotta
interrupt them right away is,
okay pitch the product,
but pitching the product as saying
this can eliminate all the problems
that the United States population
has with their GI tract,
come on now.
First of all, not even everybody struggles
with constipation.
And the big reason why we do
struggle with constipation
is because of our diets,
not because of our posture on the toilet.
- We've come up with a perfect
solution, Squatty Potty,
a simple stool that's
been carefully designed
that allows the user to
squat in a healthy position-
- Essentially, a very
inexpensive piece of plastic
that could essentially be
anything to lift up your legs.
- And when not in use
it stores neatly away.
- Neatly away as he
shoves it back one inch.
- Squatty Potty will be the
goose that lays the golden egg
for you guys and us too.
- Now who wants to climb on board,
and help us get America-
- Bobby, Bobby, how do
you squeeze out a profit?
- He hit him with a dad joke right away.
He saw the healthy colon,
and he wanted to squeeze out a profit.
- It takes an advanced sense of humor,
I don't expect everybody to understand.
- How do you sell them, to who?
- They're all available online.
We have a website.
- There's no retail?
- And Amazon.
We're not in retail yet.
- Holy crap.
You're selling-
- Holy crap, right?
There's a crap load of
money in Squatty Potty.
- No, seriously, you're
selling 2.7 million online?
- [Lori] I think I know why-
- Yes.
- [Kevin] Why?
- Weren't you just on Dr. Oz?
- Oh no, it's going dark,
it's going brown.
It's getting flushed.
- In 2012 we were on Dr. Oz.
- Yes.
- That's how we got
that $1 million, right,
and you know what Dr. Oz said about it?
It works.
- That's the first time we've heard that.
- Why can't somebody
just get a stack of books
and lift their legs?
- They can.
Well said fellow shark.
- Squatty Potty is designed
specifically for the task.
It's perfectly angled.
- Well, it can't be perfectly angled,
'cause you don't know the height
of the individual using the toilet.
Pam and I are gonna need
different Squatty Potty heights.
- I think it's very, very difficult
to get people to change
their minds about things.
We're used to going the
toilet a certain way.
- There's actually actually
some evidence behind squatting,
so I can't knock this product,
but I can say that we
just need to be careful
with the marketing of
♪ A healthy, happy colon ♪
♪ La la la la la ♪
- Because people who
have serious colon issues
will think this will be the solution
and ignore legitimate treatment.
You have no idea how many of my patients
who have legitimate symptoms that worry me
about a potential colon cancer
or inflammatory bowel disease
that refuse to get colonoscopies,
and wanna try things like this
as an at home remedy
years before they seek out
real medical treatment,
which could make it too late.
- Well, I feel that the
350,000 for 10% is right.
- How about 10% for 500,000?
- I don't accept that.
If you're interested, if
you really want a shark,
then you would entertain that seriously.
- Actually we're gonna take Lori's offer.
- Wow.
Okay.
And the rest is history.
How much money does Squatty Potty make
over the last five years?
Right here on screen,
probably way too much.
The Squatty Potty, reluctantly I'm in.
- Oxygen is the most essential element
for the heart, for the brain,
and for the muscles to function.
And we've all seen supplemental oxygen
being utilized by
professional football
players in the sidelines,
aviators, mountaineers,
and by many other people
for many different purposes.
- Usually those purposes
are for altitude purposes,
where partial pressures change.
- Boost Oxygen is 95% pure
aviator breathing oxygen
compressed into affordable and
portable aluminum canisters.
It's an all natural product
for health and wellness.
- Yo, check this out.
Mad health and wellness for free
- Our mission at Boost Oxygen-
- Oh my God, it has flavors.
Yo, you ever try that pink
grapefruit oxygen though?
- And, Kevin, if we sucked
all the oxygen outta this room
we'd all be literally
dead to you right now.
- Buy our fake product.
- So what we're gonna do,
we're all gonna try the oxygen.
- Oh my God, there's an oxygen one
that is called the think
tank that boosts memory.
My memory's about to explode.
- So you take the mask,
you put it under the
nose and over the mouth,
and you press a trigger.
- One, two, three.
- And what do you get from that, bro?
You breathe all day.
You took a little breath of oxygen,
it's not like your,
your body physically can
take in more oxygen.
You realize that, right?
Like there's a specific set of oxygen
percentage wise in the air.
It stays that way no matter
how high you turn it up.
And even if you turn it up momentarily
for your little one second burst,
that changes nothing.
- It's a $1 million capital investment
for a 5% equity stake in Boost Oxygen.
- Oh my God.
$20 million company right
there to sell you air.
- Who's using this?
- Nobody, I hope.
- When you go up from Florida to Veil,
and you go skiing
and you're breathing hard,
you see oxygen, like I'm gonna try that.
And you try it and you like it,
you use it when you're there,
when you go back to Florida-
- You don't need it anymore,
but we're still gonna
sell it to you anyway.
- Is this FDA approved?
- It's not FDA approved,
we're not regulated by the FDA.
- Yeah, because it's a BS product.
If they were regulated by the FDA
it would get taken off the market in 30,
it wouldn't even be let on the market,
'cause they would have to
make some sort of claim
to say that it treated something.
- My concern is you're
trying to educate people
on a problem they don't
really know they have.
- They don't have it.
Bro, bring me off this
show, I would flip out.
You know how they spill
water on each other?
I would just spill water on purpose.
- Looking at the five of us,
none of us took it and said
"Wow, this is a no brainer."
- Yeah, because it
doesn't do anything, Mark.
My guy, he's selling you
a think air container.
Hit the air container,
and then think how stupid it is.
- You're pretty sharp on
those numberonies there
when we're cutting it in half.
I think the deal's reasonable, let's go.
- We'll take the deal.
- The Varshavski's heavily out,
maybe 'cause I didn't have
my think oxygen container.
- Just imagine you're at a dinner party,
or maybe even a tailgate.
Better yet, we're at a
local bar with some friends
having some champaign.
Would anyone care for a glass?
- Sure.
- [Lori] Sure.
- I bet he's not gonna give me one.
I got a little sparkly water.
- Before you know it,
the night's over,
and it's time to go home.
- You gonna say your breath smells?
- The most important question is
are you safe to drive?
- Oh.
- And who would wanna
carry one of these bulky
old breathalyzers around?
- Well that's not the only issue,
the issue is whether or
not you're inebriated.
You might be under the limit,
but you still can be inebriated.
- So that's why I created Breathometer,
the world's first smartphone breathalyzer.
- Interesting.
- Let me show you how it works.
Simply retract the audio jack,
plug it into the smartphone,
activate the app.
Within a matter of seconds
you'll be able to know what
your breath alcohol level is.
- I need to know only one question,
and one question only.
Has it been tested by independent labs,
and compared against baseline real world
breath alcohol content machines?
- You can hale a cab with
the push of a button.
- That's called Uber.
- So please join me-
- Or Lyft.
- [Charles] Me on this mission-
- Or a rental.
Or Curb.
Or one of the many apps near you.
- Basically go ahead
and plug it into the audio
jack of your smartphone.
All you need to do is
hit the start button,
go ahead and breathe into this hole.
(upbeat music)
- You're at a 0.04 right now.
- That would be legal.
- Yeah, you're legal.
- You could technically
still get a ticket for that,
I'm pretty sure.
Just 'cause you're under the legal limit
doesn't mean that you're
completely fine to drive.
If you're at a 0.04
and still swerving, you
could still go to jail.
- I'm starting to think of this
as more of a multifunction breathalyzer.
So the next one we're
actually trying to focus on
is diabetes.
It's in clinical trials,
and it's obviously less intrusive.
- Yeah, but I don't think that
would be nearly as accurate,
especially for type one diabetics
who have to gauge their blood sugar
in order to decide how much
insulin to give themselves.
That's a very risky game if not accurate.
- $500,000 from Mark Cuban for 50%.
And $500,000 from the rest of the sharks,
we're gonna split it
for a total of 30% for $1 million,
and the power of Shark Tank,
what are you gonna do?
(dramatic music)
- I accept.
- The Shark Varshavski's out
because I heard zero research here,
only future plans for research.
- [Voiceover] Five minutes later.
- A little update here because
the Breathometer was ordered by the FTC,
the Federal Trade
Commission, in January 2017
to provide refunds for all its devices
sold between 2013 and
2015 because it frequently
understated blood alcohol levels,
and the FTC investigators concluded
the company was aware of this.
They decided to not inform its customers
despite this fact,
and continued marketing
and selling its products.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
This is why you don't take
people's word at face value
without evidence.
- In this day and age,
appearance is everything.
- Agreed.
Poor Kevin, he got zoomed in on.
- What if I told you you
could look 10 years younger-
- I would buy it.
- Without any plastic
surgery or injection?
- I would spend all my money on it.
- Face Yoga.
Face Yoga is a really
great natural solution-
- Oh, (indistinct)
- Your youthful appearance.
You wake up the sleeping
muscle in the face.
- I actually don't mind
the idea of face yoga,
I'm not mad it.
- Kevin, let's see your face.
- [Kevin] Let's not.
- Today you look great,
but if you do face yoga exercises-
- Ah, don't make a claim.
- You can look like this.
- No, come on, don't make a claim.
If you wanna reduce fat
anywhere on your body,
you cannot spot reduce.
If I have excess adipose tissue,
fat tissue on my arm,
he doing curls with this arm
will not make this arm reduce fat content.
That is a whole body approach.
So what she's recommending here is BS.
- Would you like to come up here
so that I can make you
look 10 years younger?
- Yeah, sure.
- Let's do some exercises together.
- Okay.
- I don't mind the face yoga,
it's the claims I have a problem with.
- Let's lift up the corners of the mouth
a little bit higher.
Smile,
and then stick out your tongue.
Go ah.
- [Kevin] This is not so easy.
- Oh man, that was aggressive tonguing.
- Coco, this is not easy.
Ah.
- The noises.
Thank God Bear's not in this room,
he would have a panic attack.
- There's no easy way to say this,
but it's just not a fit for me.
- I thought he was gonna ask her
if she's had work done.
- I'm out, Coco.
- Okay, thank you.
I will be laughing at
them when I become very,
very successful.
And if they come to me at that time,
"Oh, Coco, please teach
me some exercises,"
no, I will not teach them any exercise.
- You already taught them though.
- Please live with your saggy face.
- Oh, she hit 'em with the tea.
- [Cameraman] Is the shark in or out?
- I am very much out.
Shark Varshavski is out.
- I'm in the business of keeping boobs
high and dry.
That's right, boob sweat.
I know it doesn't sound very attractive-
- Boob sweat?
- And trust me, it does not
feel very attractive either,
but it is something that's very real
for so many women.
- And my patients who have larger breasts,
they do have higher rates of fungal,
yeast, candidal infections
underneath the breasts.
Actually sometimes it's
misdiagnosed as a yeast infection,
and it can actually be
a full blown cellulitis,
which means a bacterial infection.
- So I came up with a solution of my own,
the ta-ta towel.
- Ta-ta towel.
- That's right, it's a
towel for your tatas.
- Okay.
- [Sharks] Oh my goodness.
- I mean if that helps you,
especially if you're doing your hair,
and you're blasting the hair dryer,
and it's hot in there,
I could see you wearing that
to decrease the amount of sweat.
- We thought you might wanna feel
how it really feels.
(women laughing)
- I really don't need one of these at all.
- You know what, they make great gifts.
- I could see this working.
- I love that he's wearing it.
- I need the help.
Like you said, I've
made a lot of mistakes.
- So, what are you gonna do?
- I'll take it.
- I'm gonna take her offer.
- Yay.
The Shark Varshavski is in,
and I would make the best
Tik Tok dances wearing those.
Click here to find out
the part of your body
you should never shave.
Maybe not never, but definitely click it.
And as always stay happy and healthy.
(upbeat music)